Narrator:
LAUNCHED IN SEPTEMBER 1977,
VOYAGERS 1 AND 2
ARE THE LONGEST CONTINUOUSLY
OPERATED SPACECRAFT IN HISTORY.
HURTLING ALONG
AT 38,000 MILES PER HOUR,
VOYAGER 1 IS NOW THE FARTHEST
HUMAN-MADE OBJECT FROM EARTH.
OVER 11 BILLION MILES AWAY
AND 124 TIMES FARTHER
FROM THE SUN THAN WE ARE,
IT IS THE ONLY SPACECRAFT
TO EVER LEAVE THE SOLAR SYSTEM.
IN THE 30 SECONDS
SINCE THIS SEGMENT STARTED,
IT'S GONE OVER 300 MILES.
GAS DOESN'T POWER VOYAGER.
NUCLEAR ENERGY DOES,
ALONG WITH A PHYSICS TRICK
THAT HELPED IT LEAVE
OUR SOLAR SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN LEARN A LOT
ABOUT PHYSICS
BY PLAYING BASKETBALL, LIKE
TRAJECTORY AND BALANCE AND...
OOF.
ANGLES OF DEFLECTION.
BUT IF YOU ADD A TENNIS BALL
TO THE EQUATION,
THEN YOU CAN LEARN HOW VOYAGER 1
SUCCESSFULLY EXITED
THE SOLAR SYSTEM.
IT'S CALLED
THE SLINGSHOT EFFECT.
Narrator: THE SLINGSHOT EFFECT,
OR GRAVITATIONAL ASSIST,
EXPLAINS HOW SPACECRAFTS
USE A PLANET'S GRAVITY
TO GAIN ENOUGH MOMENTUM
TO ENTER INTERSTELLAR SPACE.
TO GET AN IDEA
OF HOW STRONG THE EFFECT IS,
LET'S PLAY SOME BASKETBALL
AND TENNIS AT THE SAME TIME.
ALL RIGHT, SO I WANT YOU
TO BOUNCE THIS BASKETBALL
FROM ABOUT WAIST HIGH.
GOOD BOUNCE THERE,
NOT QUITE TO THE SAME HEIGHT.
-MM-HMM.
-WHAT ABOUT THE TENNIS BALL?
WELL, THAT DIDN'T BOUNCE
NEARLY AS HIGH, DID IT?
MNH-MNH.
BUT SOMETHING
REALLY INTERESTING HAPPENS
WHEN YOU DROP THEM TOGETHER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK'S
GONNA HAPPEN?
-REALLY?
-YEAH.
I WOULD THINK
NOTHING SPECIAL.
NOTHING SPECIAL? ALL RIGHT.
WHY DON'T YOU TEST IT OUT?
OKAY.
THE TRICK HERE
IS TO HOLD IT IN A LINE
AND DROP THEM TOGETHER.
-OKAY.
WHOA, THAT'S AWESOME.
-NOTHING SPECIAL RIGHT?
-I WASN'T EXPECTING THAT.
ACTUALLY,
WHEN YOU DO THIS EXPERIMENT,
ON AVERAGE, THE TENNIS BALL
BOUNCES NINE TIMES HIGHER
THAN IT WOULD OTHERWISE.
-WOW.
-WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE.
WELL, THE THING IS THAT THEY'RE
DROPPING AT THE SAME TIME,
BUT THE BASKETBALL
BOUNCES FIRST.
SO, WHEN IT BOUNCES BACK UP
AND TRANSFERS
ALL OF ITS INERTIAL ENERGY
TO THE TENNIS BALL,
IT JUST FLIES UP IN THE AIR,
KINDA LIKE A SPACESHIP.
Narrator: SO HOW DO YOU LEAVE
THE SOLAR SYSTEM?
HITCH A RIDE ON VOYAGER 1.
JUST LIKE A TENNIS BALL,
VOYAGER 1 USED
THE SLINGSHOT EFFECT
TO HURL ITSELF
INTO INTERSTELLAR SPACE,
EXCEPT VOYAGER DIDN'T COLLIDE
DIRECTLY WITH A PLANET
TO PUSH IT ALONG.
IT COLLIDED WITH A PLANET'S
GRAVITATIONAL PULL.
AND LIKE THE TENNIS BALL,
VOYAGER 1 HAD ITS INITIAL SPEED.
BUT AS IT HIT THE GRAVITATIONAL
FIELD OF GAS GIANTS JUPITER,
SATURN, URANUS, AND NEPTUNE,
IT GOT PULLED AROUND IT
LIKE IT WAS IN ORBIT.
BUT THEN THE FORCE
OF THE PLANET'S ROTATION
AROUND THE SUN
SHOT IT OUT OF ORBIT
AT TWICE ITS INITIAL SPEED,
AND IT CONTINUED ON ITS JOURNEY
INTO INTERSTELLAR SPACE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE SLINGSHOT
EFFECT WON'T DO MUCH
FOR MY JUMP SHOT.
OR HIS.